弘法大師を拝む呪文は何でしたっけ？それはみんな覚えてるでしょう
高野山に行ったら誰も言わなく
誰でも言わなくちゃいけないでしょ
あの呪文は まあとにかくこの仏教で作った呪文っていうのは
この感情を抑えてくるだろうと思って作ったものなんですけどね
でも言葉に意味がないんだから
もう使い方によってどっちでもいいんだ
悪霊の場合でも使える
ということなんです この呪文唱えれば悪霊は出て行きますよって言ったら
そんな気持ちになりますからね
この呪文唱えればもう金縁と言うんですか
それは良くなります 言ったらそういう気持ちになってしまっちゃうんです
で そうやって呪文唱えて瞑想することもサマタ瞑想です
ですから 呪文唱える場合は解釈必要なんですね
いくらかの解釈 その解釈ないと感情は引き起こしてくれません
いわゆるストーリーがないと
呪文の呪文を支えるためにそのストーリーがあって
あの呪文を唱える ですから
この呪文文化にはすっごいストーリーがたくさんあるんです
そこら辺もすごく面白いんですけどね
呪文唱えて いかに誰か誰かさんが国の王様になったかと
すごい悪い王様が呪文によってどうやって倒したですかとかね
一文も無くて生まれたある貧しい家庭の人が
ある金財産に恵まれる呪文を知ったことで大変金持ちになったり
ストーリーとかね いろいろいっぱいあります
そこでこのジャータカ物語に出てくる人も一つありまして
このある呪文があって
それにそれ唱えられた
唱えたら雨からこの七宝が降るんだと
七種類の宝物 このルビーやらね
ああだこうだとか 金やら銀やらと何とかあります
で そういう呪文あったんだと
そこで他の人に知られて
あの人は知ってるんだと
で 捕まったって この呪文呪文唱えなさいと
で 嫌で断りますと そういうストーリーなんですから
だからいわゆる呪文があったっても
やたらに使えないということで
で これジャータカ物語のあるストーリーで
このだから菩薩も出てきますけど
この弟子と もう先生がその呪文知ってるんです
その呪文唱えたら 空からもう七つの宝物が降ってくる
だから まあそれでも究極の金持ちに億万長者になりますから
で ある恐ろしいグループがね
それ知って こんな泥棒やったり人殺したりとかね
金儲けたってももう危なくてしょうがないんだと
で ろくなお金になりませんと
あの二人を捕まって呪文唱えてもらいましょうと
そうすると楽に金持ちになるんだと
捕まったんですね 捕まったら先生は弟子に言うんですね
お前 間違ってでも殺されても呪文だけは唱えるなと
知ってることさえも言うなと
だからとにかく唱えてもらうまで縛っておいておくんですね
もう人質ですか 捕らわれて
で 自分いつでも唱えられません
それもこの星のいろいろ組み合わせがありますから
毎日できるわけじゃないんです
これも年 年 三年一回しかその組み合わせが出てこないんですね
だからなんかすごい複雑なストーリーで
とにかくその捕らわれていた時で
もうちょうどその組み合わせが出てきて
そこでまあ弟子は弟子だから
まあどうしてもそんなに珍しい組み合わせで
この呪文唱え唱えないでいるわけにいきません
で 唱えちゃっても大変なことになりましたってことになったけど
とにかくそれでもって殺されたんだと
だから仏教だから ストーリー自体は仏教だからそれ自体です
お金がもらって幸福になったんじゃなくて
かなりの人々は死にようになったんだと
だから呪文のストーリーなんですよ
仏教のストーリーだから
その中でも呪文の働きを否定しているんです
で そのすごいお金でしょう
そこでその 人をすぐ殺しちゃったんです
泥棒が 呪文唱えた人まず
なぜかというと こいつは他のところに行ってまたやっちゃえばということで
我々は金持ちになって何の意味なくなっちゃうんだと
先にこの人を殺す それからその泥棒のグループも物をお金を自分一人占めにしようとお互いに殺し合いやったりして
またまたものすごい人殺しになったそうですね
で 弟子は自分の先生はやっぱり逃がしてもらったんですけどね
先生はそれからもう村人やら国やらね
それで人を互いに人殺しになったことを見て大変残念で
そういう風に財産に対する欲が並ならぬ人間に苦しみを生まれてくるんだというメッセージでストーリー終わっちゃうんです
だから言うことを聞かない弟子がいて
大変なことになったと
で だから仏教の中にもなんとなくこの一応批判的なんですけど
この呪文の能力について考え方が入ってます
で 一応あの それで言葉にはね
あまり意味があるわけじゃないんだけど
一応意味がない言葉を使っても
我々の感情をコントロールすることをできるんですね
ですから このその感情をコントロールすることをサマタと呼ぶんです
だから感情を引き起こすことはサマタ瞑想とは言わないんですね
世の中でよくやってますから
買ってください もう もう何て言いますか
出血大バーゲンですか
まあそうやっていろいろあの嫌なことを言ったりして
この感情を引き起こす場合
それはサマタと言わない
それを逆に抑えれてくることはサマタ瞑想というんですね
ですから そんなに世の中で珍しいことではありません
サマタ瞑想サマタっていうのは
そこで仏教の世界ではそういうすべてサマタと言ったっても困ります
例えば数珠を持って時計を持って
例えば秒に個 とそれくらい時間空けて数えてみてください
結構落ち着きます だからもうそんなに難しいことでもないんです
こんなちょっとのことやっただけで
心は落ち着きます でもそんなことではあまり意味がないんだから
その中で厳密にサマタっていうのは
この心は高いレベルまで成長するためには
この無茶苦茶なシステム
どのように使えばよろしいかと
いわゆる昔から薬は世の中にあったんだけど
西洋医学ではこの薬の能力はなんですか？働きは何ですか？成分は何ですか？と厳密に勉強して
より早く効く薬作るような感じで
このサマタ世界から一部を取り出してるんですね
瞑想になる一部を そこで種類の瞑想法があるんです
これでこの行処と書いてますね
四十行処 この四十種類の瞑想がありまして
この四十種類の瞑想は仏教の世界で推薦している瞑想なんです
だから区別してほしいのは
音楽を聴いて心を落ち着くこともサマタ瞑想の一部なんですが
仏教でそれは推薦してないんです
なんかすっごい気持ち悪くなって
ものもちょっとしたことで怒るようになったところで
踊っても 音楽かけて誰かと三人二人集めて踊ったりする
それで気持ちよくなります
それもサマタなんですが
瞑想として認めてないんですね
それで仏教では四十種類の瞑想
サマタとして認めています
その理由は決して悪い方向へ解釈できません
心は良くするんであって
決して悪くすることはできません
いわゆる危険性はゼロ
例えばこういうこと 例えばこの異教で言ってるような
この絶対的な神がいるんだと
その絶対的な神を信仰して
神を賛美したり 唱えたり
神のために私の命も何でも差し上げますと
もうああだこうだとか唱えてると
神を侮辱する人々に対して怒りも生まれてくるんですね
そこで 神様のために神を侮辱する人々は片っ端から殺す
殺してもいいんじゃないかという恐ろしい怒りにもつなげる可能性は五分五分あるんです
例えばこの心混乱すると精神安定剤
LSD とか麻薬とか 飲んで落ち着くことはできるんです
でもそれ以上使ったらその人の人生は終わりと
いわゆるコントロールできないんですね
落ち着いたんだけど どういう風に落ち着いたかと
そういうのは自己管理全くできない
気持ち悪くなったら 仕事で疲れたら
会社の商売でいろんなことを苦しみ
かじったならば 酒一杯飲んだら気持ちよくなりますかもしれませんだけど
それでいいということでもないんです
だからこの安全度の問題で
世の中のいろんな瞑想法
いろいろ精神が安定する方法
ストレス解消方法というのはあるんですけど
効き目は二割だったら危険性は八割なんです
それ一番いい例で言うならば
ほとんどは効き目は一割もないんです
例えばこの音楽聴くと
このスピリチュアルミュージックもありますけどね MUSIC
FOR MEDITATION という CD もいろんな種類ありますけど
それ聴いてみてください
一本二本三本は我慢して聴いていられますけど
それからどんどんどんどん気持ち悪くなって嫌になってくるんですね
で クラシック音楽の場合もいいんだけど
聴き方を知ってるならばなんですね
聞いてない人にとっては四時間聞いたって
まあ気持ちいいというだけで聞いてもらいたいんです
みんな聞いてないんだから
もう四時間でも五時間でも二十四時間でも聞いてるんですけど
あれは本当は聞いてないんです
クラシック音楽でも何でも真面目に真剣に集中して聞いてみてください
一本 二本 三分 五分まではできます
それからお腹の中から硬くなって
どんどんどんどん気持ち悪くなってくるんです
ここら辺 耳 脳細胞の中
全部もう脳っていうのは痛み感じないところなんですけど
そこら辺まですごい圧迫感感じ始めちゃうんです
だからこれなかなか天才の人はいないんですよ
この音楽のこのバイブレーションですか
それで体をこうやってバイブレーションしてもらうんだから
脳細胞とか全部それで音で振動するでしょうに
だからそれ正しい波動で振動させるということはできませんね
知りませんだから それでかえっていいわけでもないんですね
ですから この音楽を聴いて精神が安定しますよと言っても
副作用のことはどうしますかと
例えばこの体操 いろんな体操
指圧 鍼 気功 そういうことでも心が落ち着いてくることはできますけど
でも問題はスーッと効けないんです
一回 二回 三回 四回で それから鍼なんかは釘に入れ替えないと
最終的には木で作った大きな釘で打ってもらわないと効かないようになるんです
そういう法則なんです
効かなくなっちゃうんです
やたらにできるわけじゃないんです
例えば鍼でもたまにやるんだったら
まあ年に一回とかね あるいは一生一回とか
すぐ効くんです これを頭が痛くなるたびに
お腹の調子が悪くなるたびに
もう朝も晩もやっちゃうと 2
日3日でもう効き目は全くなくなっちゃうんです
ですから ドリルで穴を開けてダイナマイトでもこの普通のあれ
何て言いますか あれやるでしょ
ああいうものでは効かなくなっちゃうんです
毎日やっちゃうと なんかね
何か薬草なんか体のあちこち入れて火をつけて効き目ありますよ
確かに でもやり過ぎはダメということなんです
あまりやっちゃうとそれで効かなくなっちゃって
ドリルで穴開けてダイナマイトでもつけてないと
それで一発で効きますけど
もう二度と病気にならないんだから
ですから このいろんな方法
世の中にありますけど
問題っていうのはそういう問題があるんですね
そこでこの効き目がなくなったというんだったら別にいいんです
他の方に行けば もし悪い影響が出てくるというならば
これはどうしますか？と
例えば音楽治療方法やっちゃうと
同じ波と音を聞くと 耳に耳に癖がありまして
耳の神経細胞死んじゃうんです
嫌で それからどうするんです
どんどん鈍感になるんです
敏感になるんじゃなくて
音を聞くと だから死んだものをまた治すために
また自然の中で音を聞かないでいて
自分を治さなくちゃいけないんですね
そこら辺みんな考えてないんです
音楽聴いて楽しいんじゃなくて
あれで結構耳の働きが疲れちゃうんです
それからリラックスさせて元に戻る
戻るまで放っておいておかないと
ですからこの危険度があるんですね
そういうわけで この今のインドの瞑想道場なんかに行ったら
このいろんなものを飲ませてくれる
大変新鮮です で いろいろ煙を出してくれる
線香という形で そこで窓のない部屋で神様のために以上灯りをたく
とかね その上でいろんな線香
それでこの三十二とかね
十六とかのこのあれ おりん固めてあって
これジャンジャンと鳴らす
鳴らすとそこでオームなんてのを唱えてるみたい
で あれ失神するだけのことなんですね
酸欠状態で で 倒れるんです
見ていると もうどんどんどんどん人倒れちゃうんですね
それで倒れれば倒れるほど
ものすごく信仰心が強くなってくるんです
やっぱり神は偉大なるものだよ
ですから この瞑想している修行道にしたっても
大体そういうことはあるんです
それはものすごく頭のいい松本智津江ですか
麻原さん 自分の道場でそういう方法をよく勉強して使ったんだからね
光は入れない 小さな部屋で分いても酸欠状態になる部屋のアルミで作ってセルを作ってその中に入れてシールをして真っ暗で
これでもう 1 日で神経を犯しちゃうでしょ
だからもう誰にも治せませんよ
そういう人々 今ものすごい活動を見始めているでしょ
今ものすごい抜群にも日本全国的に
ですから これもう治りません
一回そういう偉大なる神秘体験があったところで
それ 偉大なる神秘体験なんです
もう神経も全部脳細胞もおかしくなって壊れて
もうもう治らなくなっちゃうんですね
ですから そういういろいろ方法
工夫をね 人々もちゃんと抑えられていますからね
アンドロイドみたいなんですけど
いわゆる機械人間みたいなんですけどね
そういう危険性もあります
だからサマタ瞑想っていうのはそういうところもあるということは知ってほしい
だから もし私の話を理解できたならば
世の中の宗教のやり方っていうのは批判なしに非難なしに理解できると思います
例えばキリスト教で唱えている神に対する愛と
隣人やら人類に対する愛というのは決して悪いことじゃないんです
だからそこはもう人類愛することであるであるし
家族を大事にするんだとかね
ということで神様のことを念じたり
賛美歌を歌ったりとかして
すごくいい気持ちになると
それでいい気持ちになるだけではなくて
いい人間にもなるんです
そこら辺は決して悪いところではないし
そこでまたやっぱり五分五分だから
神は偉大なりというところで
また大変危険な感情も生まれてくる
そうやってこの世の中であるどんな修行方法でも
仏教の立場から理解するということをした方がいいんじゃないかなと思いますけどね
ご自分で ご自分で そうするともっと立派に心が成長する可能性あります
そこで仏教の世界では種類を選んで
一部は世の中にあった瞑想と
一部は仏教で作った瞑想
40種類ありまして カッマッターナと書いてるんですね
カッマッターナ 皆様のこのプリントありますけど
そのプリントにこの H 抜けてます
このカッマっていうのはまあ修行という意味で
普通は職業 仕事という意味でもあります
ターナっていうのは場所なんですね
ですから 現代日本語では職場なんです
自分仕事するところ そこでもう一つ意味なんですけど
自分の仕事は何ですかと
私は何々人ですよって言うでしょ
私は作家ですよ ライターですよと
あーだこうだとか言うでしょうね
そういう意味の言葉なんです
だからこの修行では私は会社員ですよというのはあんまり意味がないんです
私は金融関係の会社員ですいたってさっぱりわからないんです
その中であなたは何やってますかと
何何の担当ですか？ということなんです
ですから 会社員と言っただけでは足りませんし
その会社で自分が責任を持ってやる仕事は何かあるんですね
自分の担当で その意味で自分の仕事のこの担当業務ですね
まあそこまでは全部説明で
まあカッマターナとだけで覚えておいてください
それはまああまり で このカッマターナというこの瞑想の場合も
自分の担当のやり方 私はこんなやり方でやってますよという
そのその個人の瞑想のことなんですね
カッマターナというのは
例えば住友銀行に入社したとする
だからといって その人はもう住友銀行のありったけの頭取の仕事から掃除係まで全てやっているわけじゃないでしょうに
その人が 何か決まってる担当仕事をやってるんです
それはまあ その銀行であるお客さんに何かあげるでしょう
あれは何品と言うんですか？いろいろプレゼントあげたりするでしょ
そちらの担当でも構いません
で だからその人に聞けば
あなたは何やっていますかと言うと
私はこの相当品のこのプレゼントの担当です
私の仕事は偉い人々はプレゼント決めますから
そこは銀行に来たら それを箱を開けて
それぞれの窓口に適当な量を置いておくだけです
それでいいんですけど
それその人の仕事だから
そうやって瞑想の世界ではいろんなやり方ありますけど
その個人が自分の仕事としてやろうという意味でカンマッターナというんです
ですから 私たちの仏教では人に瞑想を指導するということは使わないんです
人にカンマッターナあげるというんです
何々信者さんがカンマッターナもらうために来ているんだと
それで瞑想を教えるお坊さんも
ちょっとカンマッターナあげてきますからと
いわゆるこの意味で使っているんですね
その人は自分の修行の中で
自分の担当分が何ですかとという聞きに来て
その教える側があなたはこういう仕事をちゃんとやってくださいと教えてあげる
そういうわけで カンマッターナというのは
その個人にふさわしい個人にできる仕事なんですね
会社に今日入った人に
あなたは取締役やりなさいと言ったってもできるわけないでしょうに
あんた今日来たんだから
まあ私はスケジュール溜まってますから
明日会議ありますから
あんた参加してくださいと言ったっても
今日入った人にとっては
それはもう何もできません
ですから カンマッターナというのは
その個人にできる仕事という意味なんです
そこで瞑想するんだからといって
やたらに何でもやるんではないんです
あれもやってこれもやってと言ったっても
あれはまるっきりわかってないんだから
あの瞑想もやってみるんだ
この瞑想もやってみるんだ
あの瞑想もやってみるんだとかね
世界の中にあるだけの瞑想をやってみろと言っても
何もやったことない 全てサマタだから
だから自分にできる一つやってみれば
これ科学的に見ると ああ
もう同じだとわかるんです
ですから マリア様の瞑想をやって
それから観音様の瞑想もやってみましょうと
いえ カーリ女神の瞑想もやってみようと言って
ある一人の人がマリア様の瞑想と観音の瞑想とカーリ女神の瞑想と 3つやったんだからで 3
種類の能力者で やっぱり一つの能力者がなくなっちゃうんです
で わかってないんだから一つやればいいんです
それで心はきちんと統一してきて
うまくいったならば これどんな方法でも同じことになります
まああの じゃあカンマッターナっていうのはそうやって
そういうことで 自分の仕事を選びましょうということで
仏教では四念処があります
その四念処の中から一つ選んでやってください
で一人自分で選ぶんじゃなくて
これは瞑想にものすごく詳しい
人の心をよく読める 心の心理を厳密に知り尽くしている
人のこともまあ心配する心を持つ誰かに教えてもらわなくてはならないんです
自分の担当の仕事は自分で決めるもんじゃないんです
それはやっぱり目上の人が判断して決めるものです
だから この40種類を勉強したっても
何の役にも立ちません
じゃあ私はこの40種類を勉強して
自分にふさわしい瞑想を選びますよ
それは不可能 それはもう誰かが教えてあげないとダメなんです
じゃあまあそういう話をやめて
一応内容に入りましょう
これは40あります ここで書いてます
そこで性格分析があります
で 性格分析っていうのは
この あの 今ヨーロッパ的で流行っている人の性格分析ではなくて
あの瞑想 いわゆる担当の仕事を人に任命するときはどうやって任命すればいいかということなんです
それぞれの人の性格を見て
この性格にこの瞑想 この性格にこの瞑想と
先生は決めるためにある性格分析なんです
そこで性格分析っていうのは
これすごい難しくて複雑で
これはまた問題なんですが
なかなか難しいんです
仏教の場合 一番基本的にはつに分けてつに分けてます
これはラーガチャリタ
ドーサチャリタ モーハチャリタ
ディタッハチャリタ サッダーチャリタ
ブッダチャリタと で このテキストに名前あると思います
275ページ これあの柱として柱としてつに分けて
でも人類は明確にこのつ
つの中で一つに入るわけじゃないんです
その中からまた小さな小さな枠はたくさん作らなくちゃいけないんですね
そこでやっと自分がどちらに入るかと
決めなくちゃいけないんです
でも このつ理解しておくと
これは先生たちの先生がこのつ理解しておくと
相手の性格はまあそれほど苦労しなくてもすぐすぐわかるんです
一応ここら辺から説明始まります
あの 1番目はラーガチャリタと言いますね
これはこちらは貪世と書いてますけどね
まあパーリ語でたくさんの言葉がないんだから
このラーガチャリタという言葉を使ってますけど
いわゆる欲張り屋ですね
欲張りという意味じゃないんです
それはちょっと悪い言葉で
まあ貪声でいいんです
で こういうこと 自分の生き方の動力
[音楽]自分が何によって自分の生活をね
回転させてますかって
このエネルギーの元なんですね
そのエネルギーの元はやっぱりむさぼり
むさぼりというのはこの楽しみ
ああ 面白いと というこの喜び
楽しみだけ目指して生きてるんです
だから普通はまあ普通なんには他の我々と同じく
全く同じく普通に生きてますけど
やっぱりあの部屋を掃除したっても
どうですか 綺麗になったでしょうとかね
そこでなんかそのそこ
その欲なんですね だからいつでも何か自分がこの自分の六根をね
満たしてくれるかということで頑張っちゃうんです
楽しみを目指して もうその機動力になる
むさぼりが機動力になると
それはあの貪瞋痴ですね
まあラーガチャリタと言うんです
で 判断する方法っていうのはあのこちらでもあまり明確に書いてない
これは悪用されますから書かないんです
あのこちらに書いているのはほとんどベテランかもしれませんだけど
あの アビダルマのテキストはあります
そこを読んで理解すれば
でもあれ読んでもわからないようにすごい上手に書いてるんです
あの仏教の考え方知ってるんだったらね
何のことなのか分かりますけどね
別に隠してるわけじゃなくてね
まあそんないい加減他人を判断してはいけませんしね
ですから まああまりわからなくないかもしれません
いくらでいくらで言いますけど
まあ  例えば何かこの机の上で自分が誰かに住所を書いてあげたくなる
一応住所を書いてくれませんかと
そこで書き方いろいろあるでしょ
こちら机があって こちら人があって
あんたの住所ちょっと書いてくれませんかと
それは書き方いろいろあるんで
そこでもう性格わかるんです
すごいその点で簡単ですね
だからそのやり方はあんまり言うべきかないかと私はちょっと悩んでますけどね
もしヴィパッサナー瞑想でちょっと性格でもよくなってるんだったらね
堂々と言いますけど 智慧が発達しているかないと試してないんです
そういう個人的な付き合いはないんだからね
個人的に知ってるんだったら試してみますけどね
だから知りませんしね
ちょっと だから教えたってもあまりわからないかもしれません
で 一応例で考えてみましょう
だから人が私は人に住所を書いてくださいと頼む
こちらに机もあります
そこでラーガチャリタの人がいたならば
机だけ椅子もあるでしょうね
椅子をちゃんとここに置いて
まずこれをただこうやるんじゃなくて
こうやってやっておいて
ここも片付いて こうやって
こうやって片付いて 時計もおそらくここら辺に置いて
ちゃんと座って あの こうやって書くかもしれません
すっごい綺麗でしょ？もう
かっこいいんです で そこはラーガチャリタなんです
貪勢なんです ん？で この次に次にこれいろいろトラブルありますけどね
そんな簡単に判断できませんだけど
一応人そこに住所を書いてくださいって言ったら
そこでラーガチャリタでそういうことなんです
それでわかりやすいんだからそう言ったんです
そこでドーサチャリタの人が来たとする
また元に戻しておかないと説明できませんだけど
で 今回これも広げてやりましたしね
こうやって 私の性格バレちゃいますよ
これで 私はこの逆も私厳密にできますけど
だから あの  判断するのは勝手になっちゃいます